so now I have a bunch of questions uh
before we get into Pacific Rim I have
what we call some curveballs probably
the most important question is right up
front all right if uh has if someone has
never seen a studio gibl movie what is
the one they should start with
wow I don't know we the first one I mean
I saw the work him and takahata uh were
doing in toyi when I was a kid and then
many years later when I saw the first ji
movies I said that that's like the
movies I saw as a kid so they have such
a recognizable seal uh but I think it's
always good to start start with tooro
you know because it's the power of
miyasaki is that he shows you something
that is impossibly beautiful and
painfully beautiful this is something
that very few filmmakers do when
something is so absolutely staggeringly
beautiful as a piece of art that you
understand that you will never
experience it in real life you at the
same time gain it and lose it meaning
you you get a sense of almost Melancholy
and you're moved to tears because when
tooro started I started weeping and I
never stopped during the film because it
was at the same time h a childhood that
was gaining and a childhood that had
never been so I think that's a great one
to say Hardware you have an amazing
resume but there's going to be people
out there who have never I I can
type I
vening people have never seen there's
going to be people out there that have
never seen anything you've done before
so if someone has never my
mother if someone has never seen a gildo
Toro film uh what is the one you'd like
them starting with and why oh I don't
know I mean I don't know I mean like for
example the movie we saw today I Absol
lutely adore you know Pacific I
I Adore depends like to me the thing is
my preoccupations and my images go from
one genre that is gigantic to something
that is very intimate so it's like when
when when you study filmmakers you
admire like Hitchcock Hitchcock has a a
site of him that is pure melodrama the
best one of those is notorious in my
opinion then he has intimate really
psychological and dark movies the best
one of which is shadow a doubt then he
has spectacle movies and the best one of
which are arguably either North by
Norwest or the birds so and and so on
and so forth so depends on what you want
to do if you're going for kickass I
would go Pacific Rim if you're going for
beauty and weirdness I would go to
Crimson Peak if you're going for I mean
the the more intimate movies I would go
p in Devil's wag or shape of water but
so you know whatever I mean if you don't
like it don't watch another if you like
it watch
another uh which of your which film in
your resume changed the most in the
editing room in ways you didn't expect
and I guess I should caveat without
mimic you know what I mean like yeah
well actually mimic in the editing room
was pretty steady that's what is weird
all the crap came during the shoot the
editing was actually you know pretty
steady because once they saw that it
worked that it did what it me was meant
to do they they increasingly left me
alone so no I think I think that uh what
you what happens is you discover this
movie for example we had two editors and
I needed a change of editor because uh
you know we when you go through a movie
that is takes this long or is this
complex you know you want to shake it
and and and once you went through four
five months of post the editor and you
have the same point of view you know so
you you need to bring somebody else and
and this movie uh was really it
benefited from that we split the attack
the Hong Kong battle and two we were
able to split the
flashback uh to Michael's childhood we
did a lot of stuff that was very
adventurous in this film I could be
wrong but I read that there was like an
hour of footage that you took out is
that true or not that's always the case
sure but but I read every movie I've
ever done is three hours in the first
God I I read that there was a lot more
stuff in the First Act of the film than
you ended up removing yeah because it
was
yeah so you're not missing anything
right so for fans they're not missing
there's no scenes you no like like for
example nare Aly has another hour that
is fantastic that I I would love to do
like a three-part miniseries with ninar
Ali because a lot of those stories that
Kim Morgan and I wrote were sort of
intertwined in a beautiful way and that
I would love to put back so I I specific
question about that I know that Hulu is
doing like this six-part and I could be
wrong about six part uh version of
Australia you know the huge acman movie
uh uh and is there any chance with Hulu
or you know Disney Plus or one of these
kinds of things um I feel like the audio
went out oh no there it is uh that is
there any possibility
of doing that with nightmare alley I
would love to I would love to I mean I'm
I'm I'm always game for more work I mean
I I I really am a workaholic so you know
I don't know what to do with free time
well I hope that happens actually um
what do you think would surprise people
to learn about being a filmmaker in
Hollywood on on your level which is
someone who gets to you know make
personal films but big films like I
guess I just want to pull the curtain
back on what it's like for you you in
Hollywood yeah it's horrible I mean it's
horrible always what I mean it's not
it's not horrible it's a great
profession and it's great to be in
Hollywood or in Spain or in every
everywhere you are but what is very
funny is uh when you look at a career
from the outside you're looking at a
career that seems to have some order or
you think it was planned but is what
happened I mean I I I always say this
statistic but lately I counted finally I
counted the screen I've written more
than 40
screenplays 40 I made 12 movies so there
are more than 30 screenplays that never
got made and and and that were written
or co-written with somebody and and uh
that means uh between one movie and
another like you see them now and you
say and then he did no then it's five
years where I didn't work five years
years where I didn't direct Kronos uh to
mimic is five years mimic to Devil's
backround five years five years so it is
every career always you are every time
between movies they they think I'm
joking when I say I'm unemployed but you
basically are as a director and every
movie you go out with is you should
always consider because it could be your
last
movie and and people think that there is
something that you know when people say
when you get there what the do you
mean by that where is there I've never
been there cuz you never get there
because there is no there there's there
for five filmmakers in the world if that
and I one of my best friends in life
more than 30 years of friendship is Jim
Cameron and I have seen
Jim as a as a friend every time have so
much to overcome in making the next
movie not only technically and all that
that everybody knows but just pushing it
through pushing it through because he's
always trying things that haven't been
done and when you try if you're going to
do a you know I I don't want to say
names but if you want to do something
that is super safe well I don't know i'
I've always done the movies that nobody
else is doing that sound crazy in paper
and and you pitch them and people
validate your parking ticket and you on
your way oh I'm I want to do a civil war
fairy tale uh that where the girl dies
at the end oh fantastic you know nobody
wants to do it Pinocchio uh almost 20
years to get Pinocchio made uh and keep
going I mean this movie was great
because Thomas stall from and John Jing
at legendary wanted it and they gave me
the 10-page treatment that Travis beum
had written and I said oh hold on a
second giant Robert
jant you're kidding right I mean because
I'm G to go I'm G to go do it and and we
went really fast but even then we had to
do it for a for a number and we had to
put the
scale of it with a number that is big
don't don't get me wrong if if I get
that money I would be very happy I would
move to Brazil and they canot extradite
me but to make the movie it was 50 60
million shorter than another movie of
that size that year it was it was tight
we did it so we have to be very smart
about the resources but I always say and
this comes from being Mexican you know
you you have to have you have to Define
as you direct I always say is this
meatballs or is it gravy meatballs you
put like and you have to do big gestures
like for example if you watch shape of
water water it's a movie that costed
$19.3 million but I knew I needed to
open with a big gesture so people go oh
you know and so I open with the
underwater apartment and her floating
and then I went to a bus and I went to a
big big government facility and then I
went into a long Corridor and a big lab
and you went oh it's a big movie no it
isn't if you stay for the rest of the
movie we're on the same three
sets the rest of the time but you do
that gesture and then there's always a
sequence in the middle that you say okay
I'm shooting four pages a day but for
this sequence I want seven days and you
take that sequence and you make it count
and and then you do another gesture a
little later and those are meatballs the
rest the gravy you got to do quick well
you know something I like the way you
just flowed with your answer let's move
on to something else I like it but what
was it uh I think I asked about making
movies in Hollywood and what would
surprise people it was a good answer uh
good figure when you look back on your
old like on Pacific Rim it's been 10
years yeah when you look at it again do
you see shots that you wish you could go
in and tweak or do you accept that once
the movie is done and you've let it go
and it's been released that that's the
way it's going to be and it's not really
something to touch again do you know
what I mean like can you let it go oh
yeah absolutely absolutely because
a movie is a capsule of where you are
like I was saying for you guys is
filmography for me is
biography like I was I was a mediocre
brother a halfwit uncle not a great
tremendous weekened father like I failed
in my personal life to make movies you
know you cannot do both you cannot be
really great at what you do and really
great at everything else you got to
decide look this is what I'm going to do
and and so it's a biography this is when
I missed the birthday this is when I
wasn't you are absent of a lot of your
personal life so to then say I'm GNA go
back and change what what came out of it
no no you don't you don't do that I I
don't do it I mean I tried with one two
goddamn shots on blade two that I hate
uh which is the fight in front of the
lights and it didn't work so God was
saying you sit sit there man Christopher
Nolan recently had a tremendous success
uh releasing Oppenheimer and IMax IMax
70 it was an amazing experience uh when
I witnessed it in that format I'm just
curious if uh cuz we're in IMAX right
now and I love IMAX it's my favorite
format I love the the everything about
this so my question is have you thought
about shooting a upcoming project using
you know IMAX cameras for the whole
thing uh and I'm just curious what the
sucess ESS of Oppenheimer do you think
that's opened the door for More film
studios thinking about IMAX as a you
know shooting you get where I'm going
with this yeah yeah well I haven't
talked to anyone at the studios because
we were in a strike so I'm a hyphen it I
had three reasons not to talk to anyone
at a studio so I stayed uh yeah I made
model kids on Sundays you know so why
what happened I don't know what happened
in the studios but I can tell you uh
almost in every big movie that's the
first thing you you try and the first
thing that in my when when I make the
movies I try to make make them for half
the budget to get twice the freedom
right so that's the first thing Pacific
R was going to have a sequence in IMX
and when they said you have to do it for
this number that's the first thing you
have to take out so I don't have that
luxury I I am still a guy like uh uh I
say this with I'm I'm very happy where I
am because I'm only doing now what I
call bucket list movies I only I'm
making only movies that I want to do
before I croak and like I really really
want if you see one I'm doing it means
it really matters to me it really is
more vital than ever and and but but is
the first thing they take out of the
budget when they say you have to do it
and you go well that's that's a lot of
money I have to take care out that's the
first L luxury you have to sacrifice
unfortunately but hopefully that if that
changes I'll be delighted man IMX is an
amazing format recently uh you
acknowledged that you were working on a
Star Wars film a number of years ago and
I'm just curious how close did you
actually come to being in the director's
chair helming a Star Wars film well I
believe a movie is going to happen when
the Blu-ray comes out that's what that's
when I know it's going to happen you
know so it it always in the last moment
things go away I've had it happen many
many many times uh we had
uh the rise and fall of Jabba the HUD so
I I was super happy we were doing a lot
of stuff we were and then uh you know
it's not my property is not my money is
one of those 30 screenplays that goes
away you know and I sometimes I'm bitter
sometimes I'm not I always turn to my
team and say good practice guys good
practice we designed a great world we
designed great stuff we learned so you
you can never be ungrateful with life
you can you know whatever life sends you
there's something to be learned from it
so you know I trust the Universe I do
when something doesn't happen I go why I
tried to have a dialogue with myself Why
didn't it happen and and and the more
you swim upstream with the universe the
less you're going to realize where
you're going so you know I don't I don't
I don't take it the mountains of Madness
though that was really hard because and
and and it was tough there are certain
things there are moments that I remember
in in the career where it's you feel the
oxygen is leaving the room and you you
want to and and most of them are kept
secret you know people don't know what
that means or they never learned about
it mountains of Madness was very tough
the release of this movie was very very
tough uh the release of Crimson Peak
which was released as a horror movie and
it wasn't and I kept saying it's a
Gothic romance released as such about
the Crux of the thing is her Passage
through this mystery is not and it was
released
straight out as horror movie so those
are things where you feel the the
bumps but um but you know the the when
something doesn't
happen you you you came up with a couple
of good ideas and you may use them later
jumping into Pacific Rim and I have an
awful lot of questions yeah when I got I
asked people to uh submit uh if they
wanted tickets to this uh one way was to
write me something and I said this
earlier when we were um uh when I was
introducing the film I had a lot of
people that were like said that they
were 11 or 12 or 13 years old when um
Pacific Rim uh was released and how much
and how much it meant to them I think I
was 12 but I mean there's people in here
like uh that person right there great oh
man I like this right so but like people
that really meant a lot to them and I
didn't realize because I'm older how
much it meant to that generation yeah
how much were you aware of this yeah
well not not aware like what I make
movies that like I will I I now know I'm
58 I know that I will never be able to
show everybody every facet of what I am
creatively because there is no not
enough time and those 30 movies that
didn't get made I'm not going to make
them at 80 you know so but you try to
send them to the world movies for you as
an audience when you're 11 Pacific Rim
is one of those is a movie that has the
heart the craftsmanship of somebody in
his 40s but the passion of somebody in
his uh early teens somebody that really
gets high on his own Supply you know uh
and and and when I do that I always say
whoever watches this movie at 9 or 10 or
11 I envy that person and I love it's a
love letter from me to that person every
movie I do every movie I do is that is
you you'll get to know me more seeing
the movies than taking a road trip with
me you know it's it really is that so I
always say whoever liked Hellboy will
one day discover Pence Labyrinth or
shape of water or this or that and and
that's my relationship with the audience
that I cherish because it's not about an
audience being large it's an audience
being deep I read again this could be
wrong that at one point Tom Cruz might
have been in Pacific R oh yeah no the
the two the two models for Pacific grim
and the two models for the screenplay
were whoers with jein Hagman and Top Gun
you know so uh the part that R Ela plays
Tom Cruz was going to do it and and I
even had a karaoke
scene and and uh the deal couldn't be
made he wanted to do it we you know we
were developing stuff and uh he couldn't
do it and I thought you know what let's
go for Idris Ela man he's a God you know
and obviously I had to rewrite it for
that but I thought it was going to be a
an interesting analog to to do to do
that and it would have been a lot of fun
I have developed three movies with Tom
Cruz and and none of the three times we
have worked but uh we have had quite a
laugh you know I like it I like I like
it look it's my life is so weird I I
really I'm like Forest Gump I
all of a sudden I'm I'm I'm I'm places
that I don't know how it happened but I
go he I like
it and and and and and honestly is I'm
grateful I'm very grateful and because
there's a saying in in movies and it's a
really great saying they say take the
Scout don't make the movie because when
you you're scouting you are in a in a
basically a van trip a bus trip with a
bunch of people eating in great places
and having a great time is my favorite
part of movies like when I planned the
Devil's Backbone I I made an itinerant
through Spain where they saw the best
sausages the best asparagus you know and
we were in SC in Scotland Scouting For
the next movie and I was mapping where
there was a good a good macaroni and
cheese pie and it's so funny because
I've heard from other filmmakers and
they some of them dread the location
scouting and but I tell you the Hobbit I
was there two years and we and when we
were scouting we were scouting they gave
me a
helicopter and I was like oh so I would
say let's land on the top of that
mountain and have
lunch we were we were we were
helicoptering by the glacier
I saw glaciers that were made of
fluoride
green bright green and I saw glaciers
that were blue I saw Glacier I mean it
was the whole two years the Scout and
then I got attacked by sandflies which
was a disaster but other than that we we
we would it was amazing and and so my my
best memories are prepar the movie and
you still have lunch with remarkable
people
I I just want to be surrounded with
great people because it's ultimately
socially and absolutely
useless I I'm inept socially so the best
companionship I have is
co-workers you know and and I work with
people I admire and people I want to
learn from I want to I want to discuss
one line in a design because whoever
says this line and a 10 degree curve is
the same thing they're not designers any
single change changes the entirety of
the design so when we design a movie uh
80% of my work is
submerged people just see it but if you
believe it that means we designed it
well but I I think a lot of people in
here are curious and I'm not sure how
much you've ever said but how close did
you come to actually directing the
Pacific Rim sequel how far along had you
developed the script you let's talk a
little bit about that I didn't see the
final movie because that's like watching
uh home movies from your ex-wife you you
know is is terrible if they're good and
worse if they're bad or the opposite
like you don't want to know you don't
want to know so I I I didn't I didn't
see it uh but I do I did read the final
script and it was very different the
some of the elements were the same but
very different
uh my the main character for me in many
ways was Michel Michael Mory and and it
was uh we were getting ready to do it it
was different from the first but it had
a continuation of many of the things I
was trying to do and uh then what
happened is I mean this is this is what
it's crazy right uh they had to give a
deposit for the stages at 5:00 p.m. or
we would lose the stages was in Toronto
for many months so I I said don't forget
we're going to lose the stages and five
Club came and went and we lost the
stages and they said well we we can
shoot it in China and I go what do you
mean
we I'm going to go through shape of
water do you think that there was
because the film this film was so
successful in China do you think there
was an element at the studio and I'm
just this is hypothetical that they
wanted it shot in China it didn't matter
to me what it was what I did is I write
a phenomenal part for Don Yen I wanted
Don Yen I wanted to to have Don Yen
staring a damn movie a mainstream movie
I was all for it and we did Scout in
China again and we scouted this and that
and I we were going to do location
shooting but stage I I wanted to be in
Toronto you know for sure so we had to
you know there's a thing in stages where
you you're challenged meaning you have
the first hold and then uh you get
challenged and if you don't put the
deposit you lose them so we had we lost
them and then I got a couple of the
smaller stages for shape of water you
love Toronto what is it about Toronto
that you because you you're up there all
the time shooting what what is it about
that City well first of all the crew is
fantastic the crew is fantastic in
Toronto I know the city really well uh I
I shot the first movie I shot there was
in 1996 was mimic so I I I I know it
quite well is it's there's a cultural
life that I like there's great two
things I need in life great bookstores
and good restaurant in that order I
guess and and and it has both so you
know I I I enjoy it quite a bit I I love
Toronto me too love and you and Tiff you
can go I I do m classes in in in in the
cinematech and I I I give four or five
classes in a row about Alfred Hitchcock
or Louis buuel or uh Gothic romance and
and we watch movies and then I discuss
them with the audience and we have a a a
sort of day by day we put together a
little bit of a particular part of
Cinema and I I love that or I go to to
other people's uh master classes or I
interview people on stage there's a very
active uh Cinema life in Toronto there's
a lot of Die Hard fans in here is there
anything what do you think would
surprise hardcore fans about Pacific Rim
to learn about the making of Pacific Rim
oh my God nothing I don't know what
would it surprise them I don't know uh
you
know the maybe the editing BR I don't
know there's nothing uh there was a lot
of work we created a lot of language
that now I see in other movies like we
created a lot of the language of uh
bright colored neon fights in the rain
and at night I was calling the style of
it GOC which a mixture of Gothic and
Tech so I said let's do a movie that is
gothic that that that has what the
Japanese called wabisabi which is the
the beauty of the imperfect and
impermanent uh what does it mean George
Lucas uses wab Savi on Star Wars which
means everything that you see is not new
is dented patched rusting corroded and
that adds a beauty and a reality to the
layer if you think science fiction the
biggest leap it took uh other than
cubric the biggest leap it took was
George coming in with WBY Savi and
making that Universe Rusty use sweat you
know it has all the reality of a real
world and uh there's nothing on POS I
didn't want a movie that was
triumphant I said I'm not going to make
a movie about one country winning the
war I refuse to do that I want to make a
movie about Humanity winning the war and
not having the tools it's not going to
be about everything being shiny and cool
it's going to be everything about being
Rusty and old and cool cuz I think old
is cool and I love I I I I am an an
animist I talk to my
car I get in my car every day is a car
I've had for 13 years I love my car I
call him El Guapo and and I I get into
my car and I I said come on let's go to
work I talk to it I talk to things in my
house that's how lonely I
am no this is really I and I believe
that like the Japanese that every object
has a soul so I wanted to make the
robots
Soulful and have a personality not just
look cool or shiny shiny to me is
horrible Beauty the beauty is not
Perfection it's
imperfection and and every single thing
in Pacific room is Rusty
dark covered with water and I've I've
seen some of those gestures appear in
other films and and I like that I I
think uh because I watched all the Kaiju
movies carefully to see what was done
that worked and what was never done that
I wanted to try and we went through
enormous lengths to do the accumulation
of rain in the corners I said imagine
that is a cathedral fighting in a
cathedral if you go to the corners
there's an accumulation of water that
trickles and I said imagine that some
robot taking the punch has many points
of Fugue where that water is trickling
and we track every one of them I think
the only thing that may surprise an
audience is that we use the actual
models everybody thinks it's old
CG there's a couple of scenes where we
actually did Miniatures and Destroy them
very very pointedly the scene where the
fist goes into the office that's a giant
maxiter of the office and we had real
desks with little papers little staplers
little coffee CBS ilm tweeted some
photos I put on Twitter if anyone had
any questions and they responded with
four behind by the way go to Blue Sky
and God damn it it's cool uh by the yes
I yeah Elon can go f himself um that's a
whole another thing um I I'm curious
because you're making this obviously on
a budget every movie has a budget and
you know that these VFX shots are going
to cost a lot of money in the writing
phase are you thinking about okay we're
probably going to have the money to do
three set pieces or four set pieces
whatever that number is we need how are
you figuring out where you want to spend
the money in a movie like this and is it
in the writing phase or do you see what
I mean well when you're writing if
you're bored writing it they're going to
be bored watching it it's extremely
simple you're writing and you go I don't
want to be
here then you shouldn't be there why
don't don't it's like most of the time
when a when a scene needs a score you
should cut it
out it may benefit from score that's
different but if a scene needs score
it's a bad scene you should say I should
consider cutting it and the same is true
on the screenplay you have to pce
yourself and stay interested when when
Kim Morgan my wife and I we could Ro
nightmare alley that's how we BCE it if
if she was bored reading what I wrote or
I was bored with reading what she wrote
We would say this is not working
and I think uh you know you you you you
don't worry about the budget until it's
time to do that I don't think you want
to be like that you you I have it in the
back of my mind because I was raised in
the Mexican Cinema industry and you're
very I'm very fiscally responsible but
but it doesn't it shouldn't stop you
like when when we were doing Hellboy One
uh they said you have to cut 10 million
I said then I'll put a an extra set
piece I will but I but you're not going
to make it smaller and I added the piece
with the pendulum where he escapes the
pendulum and and with Pacific GM what I
did with ilm uh I was raised uh I had a
company that did special effects we did
opticals we did animation we did stop
motion we did makeup effects we did
storyboards we did everything I'm a I'm
a okay painter an okay sculptor and I'm
okay miniature maker I I know how to
animate
so I have a multi-discipline background
uh that allows me to be very very fluid
when I trade what they call horse
trading and uh and bfx
means I'm going to give you 30 shots of
added blinks for the fishermen and in
exchange you're gonna you don't have to
do the fishermen swimming underwater
like you you trade sure things so with
ilm what we did which was unprecedented
by then and I don't know if they've done
it again is we came in and said let's
make a Sandbox cuz this movie is not as
big as other movies we're going to do X
number of triaa robot shots we're going
to do x uh extensions we did an
inventory an inventory and then we
traded and and it it worked we finished
the movie
Under so I I I I other than with Co or
the weinsteins I've never gone over and
those two were plagues so you know I
have an
excuse they were
pandemic I I read that you filmed the
movie in 103 days and you had a splinter
unit that you directed um and basically
you were working like 17 18 hour days
seven days a week yeah how do you
actually I shoot six days a weeks and on
Sundays I
edit okay so you actually so on Sunday
wasn't like uh you on set all day it you
in an editing room no yeah and I edit
during lunch and I and I gave
instructions to the editor before but
the result is normally normally 12 weeks
after I should I have a cut like Devil's
bagbone I completed entirely in 12 weeks
after shooting completely mixed color
corrected everything because uh I needed
to go and do blade to I needed to hurry
up because uh when they I made them wait
for me I said no I'm gonna do the
Spanish movie first I don't care and
they waited I know uh was the title
always going to be Pacific Rim did you
ever think about changing it to
something else well it was in a double
program with Jack Reacher so it was not
a fortunate program but I I it was
always Pacific Rim from the moment the
Travis vum uh came up with the 10 pages
and then we wrote uh with fleshed out
this thing together and I liked it I
like the I like how it sounded you know
I want to read this question so I get it
right what do you think of drift
compatible becoming a common shorthand
Trope across fandom and for creators in
general since still such a unique
Concept 10 years later the the that was
one of the ideas that I loved in the in
Travis's thing and I came up with the
with the term drift compatible because I
I thought it was a like I like slang
that sounds casual like you're a jockey
you're a Jer when how long since you
jock it because it's the way you you you
have the P of the profession and I I
like it I I think that uh it is what the
movie is about the movie is about two
things for me it's about leaving fear
behind and trusting someone that's it
it's two people that don't trust anyone
let learning to trust each other that's
it and because the reason I made the
movie was
melore and the reason because inside
that giant robot there is a woman and
inside that woman there is a little girl
and the fear that that robot is going to
enact is linked to that little girl
which is the way we behave every day in
our life we all are jocked by a little
child that is afraid that was damaged
when we were five or six or seven that's
the way we behave every day in life when
we're hurt uh in a relationship when we
feel inadequate that's the six-year-old
inside you piloting this considerable
body and that's what the movie is about
for me and it's about h a bunch of
losers uh getting together and doing the
best they can for each other you know
so drift compatible is key to them so
you obviously worked with ilm on these
visual effects and I'm curious what was
your reaction in that first meeting when
you said okay so I want to do this this
that's already going to be hard but now
we're going to add rain we're going to
have a sequence that's in the water oh
wait actually let's go underwater yeah
yeah yeah like so what's their reaction
and is it any how much harder is it
exponentially when you start introducing
those kinds of elements well the hard
thing you can understand this it it may
sound weird the one thing is not to
betray the mass of the things so the
fights have to be slow you know if you
don't do that
then they look like guys in suits so the
when John null uh who's a genius uh at
ilm we we did he did charts of
displacement of water and air pressure
when a jagger walks between two
buildings it said the displacement of
mass would create this and that and we
said let's let's for example one thing
we did I said I don't want any
impossible camera moves I hate cameras
that go woo
and listen by by the way anytime I'm
watching a movie and there's a shot of
drone looking down I changed the
channel please please please don't do it
please don't do it except and no one
will save you now that's a great shot
cuz there you see the circles of the
ships Landing but is that is the shot
where you go oh it's like a like don't
do it don't do it anyway we I said I
don't want any shot that is shot at out
of scale tell me if that shot is on a
little barge in the water then the
camera needs to be bobbing with it if
it's from a helicopter I wanted moving
at that at the speed of a real helicop I
don't want any you know whoosing shots
or impossible shots so we said let's
grab let's be fanciful but rooted in
reality so uh that is what made it hard
you know like when we went underwater
John said the first color to disappear
once you get to that deep is this one
this one this one and then when you go
to the bottom they they basically the
colors are gone so we had to look at the
reef maps and say this is where the reef
would be uh etc etc we scouted Hong Kong
uh thoroughly I ate how was the food
amazing and and you know in in China
they they when you visit they try to
give you food that is shocking like the
Gest has to eat the eye of the fish and
I'm Mexican I ate everything I ate the
eye of the fish the the everything po
fish but but but we we scouted we were
we were in a barge and a a ship went by
full of cargo and I said what if the
Jagger uses that as a baseball bat you
know so the the when you were scouting
you get all this feedback so we mapped
Hong Kong and then we got this piece of
news they said in Hong
Kong if you want to destroy a building
that is real you have to get a permit
from the designer the engineer the owner
and all the
tenants and he said and if it's a public
building it's impossible for it to be
destroyed because nothing in Hong Kong
would fall no matter what so what they
said you can go over the bridge Stone
Cutters bridge but you cannot destroy it
cuz it would never come down and I go
all right I get it so all we started to
REM map the fight and we didn't destroy
any building that is real but you have
to do every what I think is you have to
take everything that is if everything is
outlandish and Whimsical and great
nothing is real you have to have a layer
of reality whether with you're doing the
the physics the geography something has
to be rooted so with ilm they were all
for the challenge and listen they loved
it they were going to work with thear
and KES for months and months in a row
this we are all people that grew up with
that so uh Hal hickle and I would use
our free time and we would go to um
hobby shops in Chinatown and buy by uh
robins and monsters and I I I I love
painting models I love uh collecting um
vinyl figures so we would use it doing
that you collect I do I that is shock
yes um I know although although although
I I must say I'm I'm showing great
maturity I told uh Kim uh yesterday
morning or this morning I said I'm not
going to B on the Phantom of The
Paradise suit because I have enough
stuff I I I decided I'm I have enough
stuff although if something come out on
4K HD I will buy it I I mean I have so
many follow-ups but I am curious I know
you like to when you're making a movie
you like to make double of props or
whatever it may be so you can keep stuff
so firm Pacific Rim uh what is in your
collection I have I wanted Mao's blue
suit and her red shoes and I wanted then
uh cannibal Chow's shoe one of the
organs uh the spinal container one of
the bugs and the Escape pod so I have
all of that and and the mettes that were
made for the movie to pitch it to
Warners and legendary which are
absolutely magnificent and Gypsy danger
in those Mett is white it was it was not
this colors it was white and it was
really interesting and then we we
realize that a you lost a lot of detail
if you photograph white because white
eats the detail same with red red eats
all the detail these are two colors that
are very voracious it's hard to get
Nuance for those who not seen the movie
there is an after the credit scene with
Ron Pearlman was it how did you decide
on that scene and was it ever going to
be something else yeah there was no
post-credit scene but we all loved run
and and then Thomas tall who's one of
the great the greatest Studio
head that I ever met because he's a fan
he is he really was really was a fan
yeah huge fan a huge fan and he said if
if if they gave you money what would you
sh post C I said Hannibal CH saying
where is my goddamn Sho you know so we
did and Ron was super happy to to do it
again yeah how much was did he was
because there's like the goo on him oh
that was goo yeah was was when he when
you tell him something like that is he
like bring it on or is he like really do
you really need me to have goo it
depends depends on the weekend he's
planning you know sometimes sometimes he
wants to go home earlier you know no but
Ron Ron and I have gone through
everything so you know like one thing
you may know or not know this anecdote
but Idris Ela before we strapped him for
the final battle he said um I just don't
want to get wet and I said to him oh
don't worry don't worry and I we
strapped him and then you you screw the
control to the suit he cannot move and I
said open the
water and I you could and I will
disclose this without saying the name of
of the actor one of the actors got
diarrhea and we couldn't unhook him in
time so there was drift compatibility of
a different
kind for a moment we all went ah cut the
lunch one of my favorite shots in the
film is the and you mentioned it earlier
is the child's perspective of the attack
um and I love the way it's shot and it's
just it's just so well done can you talk
about showing the perspective of the
child and
I mean in that sequence there was one
decision I made really really early
where I said I don't want any of the
masses running away from the monster I I
want them all to be in a refuge so that
you don't have to cut from below to
above because then the battle should be
between two things destroying a city
right and I said the only times we cut
down is going to be when the when
they're getting in the Refuge right and
in the memory of M that she must have
felt she was entirely alone in that City
so she's walking with her shoe in her
hand and no one else is there so those
were significant so I said those two
moments we will go to the ground other
than that I didn't want to do the usual
the people walking with their with the
dining table and their you know like I
wanted I wanted to stay above so
planning it what I wanted was a very
beautiful transition on camera without
effects which is Ry is talking to her
and the camera starts going around and
theatrically we lower the lights and Ash
starts coming down and she takes one
step and she's on the pavement I wanted
it to be a transition that felt almost
like a theatrical operatic and then
she is that kid and and and and I I
really thought it needed to be the
problem is you need an actress to play
that kid that is that great because we
rigged I I don't know if you know this
either but we rigged we built that
street and we rigged it with giant
Hydraulics so that every time the the
monster takes a step the whole street
jumped about a couple of inches Bam Bam
and everything jumped everything the
Halls head moved we did a lot of things
physically in this movie that that were
very challenging the the compat really
were on on shakers when they were
fighting that this things
moved from one side of the stage to the
other because I wanted the physicality
of it you you might not remember but I I
was fortunate enough to do a set visit
on Pacific Rim Yeah and the thing that I
remember most is I couldn't believe how
much like destruction you had put on
that sound stage in Toronto with um it
was just a very impressive set it was a
and what we do what we do is all the
Hong Kong streets that were shot what I
do is I plan the sets sort of like an
eight figure because you can shoot one
way and then that's one street you can
turn around and it's a completely
different street so ultimately all the
streets in Hong Kong all of them were
shot in that single figure eight and we
would leave for two weeks and they would
change the signs another thing we did
that I'm very proud of is every American
movie that takes place in Hong Kong
writes bad
Chinese and we made sure that every
single sign was written properly and
every traffic sign every uh Urban
markings on the street everything was
accurate to it was not just a Whimsy
where oh it looks okay we we went we and
we tried to capture the flavor of Hong
Kong in the future in the 2020s which
here we are you know nothing happened
this is going to be a nerdy question um
so did you ever like scientifically
figure out how they were able to
communicate through the breach or you're
like f it it's a movie oh yeah f it is a
movie no no absolutely no absolutely but
I mean we figured out a bunch of stuff
certainly uh
John null who is very very
logical said well uh the first line of
the fence would never be a giant robot
and I go no it
wouldn't next
question so there are there are certain
things you have to say well but there
would be no movie but we talked about
the other
Alternatives we we did we he we said
okay what would you use you would use
things like bunker Busters meaning
there's missiles that could penetrate
the Kaiju blah blah blah and they would
explode inside but if the target moves
even and they have no heat signature
because their their life form is based
on Silicon not carbon and their their
temperature is not track like we we came
up with a
decent uh my dog ate my homework
explanation for why they came up with
the giant robots do you consider is
Pacific Rim black the animated series on
Netflix is that official Canon or is
that like it's just a fun show no I what
we did is we the first couple of comic
books that came out we were very very
involved and I think uh there was a
moment where I just said look I'm doing
other stuff so I I have no idea what
happens in that series man I I hear is
the people like it I like that but I I
have only limited time in this life I
was doing troll Hunters man
I'm curious this seems like it could be
a really cool big video game world has
there ever been discussion about making
like a AAA title or something more than
what's on the Xbox like digital thing
look I really really really was so
involved in the creation of the toys I
wanted all the toys that I could get and
the video games we didn't discuss uh
back then I I would love that but I I am
the Albatros of video games every time I
get involved they get cancelled or or
somebody fires coima you know so I I I
better not get involved I know we're
just about out of time I'm curious if
you two last things have you as a
director seen any cool new technology or
any cool new cameras that you are
excited to be able to use as a filmmaker
I think the most exciting things that I
mean obviously when you have a big
format and you can do
experiences uh more in a park ride type
of
environment where you can make the
audience participate and and be part of
it uh I'm more interested in that for
short um
rides I think movies are you on a screen
you know and I think that's what I'm
interested in I I'm 58 I'm I'm I'm
really happy I've been there I don't
want to last beyond reasonable I don't
want to be always on The Cutting Edge I
do what I do and I'll do it while they
let me and that's it I would love to
have been involved in park rides because
I'm a big fan of that design and uh I've
seen you at Disneyland and you love
Disneyland yeah no I 100% man I mean I I
am I I love that I love uh what goes
into that and I know it quite well and I
know know very well the tricks of that
trade so I I have had I had ideas like
one of one of the ideas that we I wanted
to do for Pacific Rim and uh the tragedy
of the release of the movie was that
Warner Brothers and legendary divorced
yeah during the launching of this movie
so the movie was not launched properly
was actually sort of counter launched I
will not go into many other details
because my lawyer said don't but it was
not to the benef benefit of the movie
the way it was launched uh we managed to
do 415 million dollars blah blah blah
and and sary markets did so well blah
blah blah but that was TR but one of the
things I wanted to do which I'll tell
you because it would have been super
cool this is when laser projection was
early and have you guys been to ComiCon
at San Diego next to the convention
center there's a very large Hotel
and what I said is at night as soon as
it's dark we sound a gypsy horn and we
project in the entire facade of the
building Gypsy breaking the building and
coming out and shooting at the light
into the crowd and we put a light in one
room and Gypsy turns and destroys the
building and shines the
light I didn't want to do it and you
know but that's the type of thing I
would like to explain I would like to
but at the same time I I like uh I like
very much uh um to just stay uh
promoting the love of film as it is I
don't think technology and size of
screen yes because the difference
is uh at
home the screen obeys
us it's like sit sit bag good boy right
that's television Cinema overwhelms us
and
Demands a ceremonial servitude from us
there is every time art Demands a
certain humility it's good for the soul
humility is extremely good and and every
time you submit to a force larger than
yourself namely
scorsi good you is good for your soul so
I I like
that the art form should exist in that
way and not just be hooked on technology
I think IMX size of screens quality of
sound those are great things so you have
a lot of fans in this theater can you
tease anything about what you are
directing next well I'm doing
Frankenstein yeah yeah yeah yeah so you
know we're we're working on it we start
shooting in February and U I mean it's a
movie I I've been wanting to do for 50
years since I saw the first Frankenstein
and I had an epiphany and is basically
uh a movie that requires required a lot
of growth and a lot of tools that I
couldn't have done 10 years ago 20 years
ago and now I'm brave or crazy enough or
something and and uh we're gonna tackle
it it's Oscar Isaac Andrew Garfield uh
kristo wals Mia goth and we're working
on it can I say something thank you for
coming guys I
mean this is a movie I love and this is
as close as I can go uh to having
cookies and milk with you guys this is
as close as we can do it and this is as
I liked it to be an intimate setting I
think this is the way I saw it uh on on
the IMAX screen screen the first time I
saw it finally on 3D uh we took hundreds
of days to do this 3D we didn't do a
quick job we did it pay Jim Cameron said
you either do it for this number of days
or I'll be very angry with you and you
don't want Jim Cameron to be angry at
all and and and to me what I experienced
back then it was seeing the movie and I
made it seeing the movie for the first
time so I hope it was like that for you
and thank you for coming guys thank
you